hi I'm Dennis McCarthy the guy behind
the vehicles and the Fast and Furious
franchise I'm going to talk about every
major car from the franchise 95 eclipsed
yeah that was Brian's car in the very
first film I think back at that time you
know the paint was cool everything about
it I think it really fit its character
and I think that's a car that you know
Paul Walker live actually driven 70
Dodge Charger I mean this is the car
that I can go on for hours I mean I
think that car is really more of a
character in the franchise than just a
vehicle to car with the supercharger the
bug catcher through the years I've tried
to always keep that theme consistent
with everything that Dom drives part of
the franchise and definitely parted on
[Music]
so the 94 super that's a car too that I
feel is very iconic to the franchise I
mean you know it seems like the cars
that get a ridiculous amount of
attention would be that super and Dom's
charger and really it all stems from
that final sequence of those guys going
head-to-head
I love the launch I love seeing the
tires on Dom's charger wrinkle and that
super pretty much had everything you
could do to a Supra at that time Mazda
rx-7 the rotary motor was I think unique
the rpm capabilities it's kind of one of
my favorite imports I bring that back to
the franchise later on my favorite
aspect of that was when Dom lifts up the
seat cushion it has the multiple
miniature nitrous bottles I thought that
was just a great moment in the very the
very first one so ladies 97 Nissan 240
yeah that was a cool car you see her
running that thing out at race Wars in
the year that the very first Fast and
Furious came out that car was huge it
was kind of like that transition from
muscle cars into the beginning of the
import scene 1994 Acura Integra very
easy car to modify there was a lot of
parts available you could buy you know
intake kits exhaust kits camshafts
clutch kits that's a car that was really
part of that big movement of import
racing back in the back in the 90s the
Honda 2000 the first movie was so it was
very heavy on the imports and that's
really what it was about the s2000 was
another car it was very nimble very fast
weren't great right off the assembly
line from the factory but just with some
minor modifications you had a real
performer
[Music]
2003 Mitsubishi Eclipse bright purple it
had these gigantic polish wheels which I
think Roman or Ashley will say Tyrese
CEO was heavily involved in I think they
went through three or four different
wheel choices though the car doesn't fit
my personal tastes
I know that car was exactly what Roma
wanted to drive and as far as the movie
goes I gotta say it was perfect
the 69 yangko when I saw two fast fierce
ago man on that thing is absolutely
awesome and it's sitting here with us
today car has been restored front to
back has well over 500 horsepower as a
BorgWarner super t10 12-bolt all the key
ingredients historic muscle car the GTR
I believe there's been a GTR in every
single movie it's one of those cars it
was ahead of its time the performance is
incredible the all-wheel drive like I
said it's just some of this part of the
franchise from the beginning up until
who knows another Honda s2000 it was
modified beyond the normal it actually
had a supercharger on it that car can
literally burn the tires through the
first three and a half years I don't
really like to be seen driving a pink
car but the the horsepower made up for
it so the Mitsubishi Lancer Fast and
Furious the franchise really helped
launch that vehicle into being how
popular it became change them from
all-wheel drive to rear-wheel drive
maybe 20% rear-wheel drive you know
we've done a lot a lot of work with
those cars hopefully someday Mitsubishi
comes back out with something similar
because it kind of got away from that
performance feel that the original you
know Lance's and Evo's had but great car
[Music]
s15 this was a car that was perfect I
mean when we went to do Tokyo Drift went
out to Japan basically every car show we
want every drift event we wanted to it
seemed like 4050 percent of the vehicles
there were you know going to be an S 14
or ness15 Silvia they're so easy to make
drift or go fast or do whatever you want
to do it's almost basically like the car
was designed to become a drift car and
today if you go to a drift event
they're everywhere they put LS motors
and these things they put everything in
them so the Veilside Mazda rx-7 it was
everywhere was in every magazine and we
were able to make a deal with Veilside
for their one and only hero car sad
thing was you know of course we had a
change of color so it's almost painful
when you get a car that has probably
a thirty forty thousand dollar paint job
the orange worked out great it really
popped on screen we ended up building I
think six other replicas of that car I
take that back we built nine we had to
build a whole nother set for Japan as
well but the one car that was our hero
card that came directly from Veilside
had somewhere around 600 horsepower a
gigantic turbocharger and I dismembered
one night down a lower grand where he
literally had that car sideways just
blown the back tires off of it for
probably 300 feet so a good one once
again we bring back the Evo in Tokyo
Drift which like I said was just a car
we had to have and that was the one that
was completely converted to complete
rear-wheel drive only we didn't have to
do that much to the motor I mean we did
do some some computer work some exhaust
work but other than that it worked great
just as this so the 67 Mustang when I
read the script for Tokyo Drift the
Mustang opened up a great opportunity to
do something different we actually went
with the r34 engine in Hans suit and
Hans Silvia cool part about it was we
actually built this car it was a hundred
percent functional we actually did a
bunch of you know drag race tests you
know at brand I think 13 oh and 114
miles an hour 30 no doesn't sound that
impressive but you have to realize we
had a tires that were set up for
drifting they were very hard compound so
it burned rubber through the you know
through half the quarter mile
like I said everything you see on screen
is real the shots were the cars driving
without a hood and we got the camera
with a shot that I I begged for just
because I said look man no one's gonna
leave this car actually is a functioning
vehicle unless you actually show it with
the hood off so you know we were pretty
proud of ourselves because it was just
such a unique vehicle in Tokyo Drift we
actually had a VW van and this car was
for Twinkie Twinkie was kind of a small
guy you know looked fairly harmless but
when you pissed him off it gets crazy so
that's really the story behind the VW
van the Buick Grand National from Fast
and the Furious it's a car that was
built in a time when American
performance was really at one of the
all-time low points but the Grand
National somehow broke through with its
turbocharged v6 it was a car that with
very little modifications could dip into
the you know 12 second quarter mile
times and what we did is really just
lower the car to the ground a little bit
more with some black nascar-type wheels
on it
and goes down as one of my favorites so
fast for we get into a another Subaru
for Brian I read the script and I said
hey they're down in Mexico they're
driving through dirt roads I said oh hey
this this has to be a rally car
Subaru came up said hey we'd love to
help you out we basically put a roll
cage you know changed up the paint the
wheels and the tires eliminate all the
computer things that prevent us from
doing the stunts we need to do and boom
we're good to go so all survived up
until the end where we had a launch
amount of a tunnel I think we pretty
much destroyed everyone we had but you
know car performed flawlessly as they
always do
so the r34 you know once again this car
keeps coming back around and around and
again it comes around and around for a
reason because they're so they're so
cool I mean the skyline of GTR it's I
think it's at the top of the list Paul
Walker himself Ashley owned one he has
an R 34 1970 Chevelle SS that's one of
my personal favorites I Drive a 68 SS
Chevelle myself it worked for his daily
street car when the challenge came up to
enter the race he had to modify it you
know once again overnight Turner did
basically the gray primer version with
the American Racing wheels car featured
a big-block manual 4-speed pretty much
cool on every level
the 71 skyline one of the worst
positions you can put yourself in as a
pitcher car coordinators to have one
vintage car that needs to run and drive
everyday and that's exactly what we did
because it was obviously a car that I
couldn't duplicate unless I you know
flew one over from Japan
did everything we could to prep the
vehicle and we were driving that car and
you know I think it was a hundred degree
heat it you know falls into that
category of the the perfect car for that
scene the Gurkha military vehicle this
is a car that when Hobbs is introduced
into the franchise in five you needed
that you needed something that just fit
his character and when I saw the Gurkha
I thought you know man it's not gonna
get any better this vehicle is perfect
it's big its burly it's mean drives
through walls it drives through houses
we actually had one that was a legit and
then we had a couple that were basically
fake without all the armor plating and
everything else just to make them a
little more nimble so we had a couple of
you know what I'll call lightweight
stunt versions to go along with that
[Music]
so the 2011 charge dodge has always been
a huge supporter of the franchise and
they just come out with a brand new
model and we basically were working with
a lot of prototype cars if you'll notice
one car has the red and blues on you
know and that wasn't scripted they
somehow just got turned on by mistake
but you know in the afterwards you know
looking at the footage you know what
Roman would be the guy to colonel red
and blues on so we just left that as is
so we get into our vault heist Chargers
we basically assume that the team has
taken the cop cars that they've heisted
and you know tournament of these
vehicles to grab that vault through
through the streets of Rio which we're
actually the streets of Puerto Rico and
I tell you for those moments in the
franchise when we destroyed a ridiculous
amount of stuff that's right there at
the top I think fate of the Furious
might have it beat with a zombie car
scene but I'd say we probably put you
know 150 plus cars into the scrapyard
shooting that one one segment here we
open up and they're on this mountain
road and this was an amazing scene we
filmed us out in tenerife on this road
that was far more dangerous than
actually appeared and it appeared pretty
dangerous it was really just a great
contrast I think of the the GTR then the
Challenger going head to head with DOM
and DOM and Brian which is different
than the normal you know fast and
furious is straight line drag race
[Music]
so the Dodge Daytona this is a car that
I really wanted to build I brought it up
a few times the past I didn't really get
anywhere with it but when we got to this
film there was one brief moment we were
asking to be out on the Autobahn I said
you know what if we're going to the
Autobahn we have to have a Dodge Daytona
it's the car has the aerodynamics to
keep up with you know European supercars
I say that makes perfect sense
well the story Devia the locations
changed but the cars still stayed it's
not a replicant replication of an
original charger it's kind of my own
version where we tucked the nose back in
obviously we slammed the car to the
ground
we just streamlined everything and six
we had a scene where it was kind of like
a government-issued version of a charger
so I had a lot of fun with that we
basically did kind of like a battleship
gray paint scheme you know once again
lowered um change it up to a like a
Mopar 20-inch wheel there's really not a
lot you can do the exterior that car
because they're so cool as is and when
you do try to modify them they just
don't look right and it looked like a
car that Hobbs would have had built in
the military facility for the crew so
the Ford Escort Mark one this is a car
that's a huge favorite one I went to the
UK I realized very quickly that this is
like the Dodge CUDA of the United
Kingdom these cars are so popular there
that when we had our team of mechanics
that were the local guys I couldn't get
him to work on anything but that car if
we pulled up the set we would have a
Dodge Daytona maybe an Enzo Ferrari and
without the escort all the local you
know fans and you know people walk on
the streets with instantly flock to the
escort so I will say that the UK crew
made those cars as authentic as they
look on screen I mean everything down to
the correct valve cover the flip car
this is a really interesting car I mean
there's cars that we build that are you
know a modification of something else
and there's cars we build from from
scratch and that said the one that came
from scratch Justin came to me said hey
man I want to build a car they can run
other vehicles and launch them into the
air I said man that's awesome that's a
great idea and they were fully
functional they had a 500 horse LS motor
trooper 400 V drive unit so the motor
sat in the back
power supplied to a Dana 60 front axle
out of a Chevy truck and the rear steer
was basically a system that we you know
Rob from them from the monster truck
industry where he had a toggle switch
that could a
self-center or maintaining that angle as
long as you want I think was the ideal
thing for Shah to be driving it kind of
showed Shahs technical side and what he
was really about the Jensen interceptor
is a car that
Michelle Rodriguez still gives me a hard
time about today she really didn't like
that car at all she this cars idly I
don't want to drive it I said look this
car is perfect there's nothing better
you're in London you've lost your memory
there was no other choice I was totally
just dead said I said this has to be in
the movie it's the right car there's
nothing that matches your character at
this point in time and in this location
then the Jensen interceptor
[Music]
so the Navistar military tried the cool
thing with with that truck it was a real
one that was loaned to us from Navistar
it had every single you know piece or
modification that you would find out you
know in the middle of a you know a
hostile military environment it took a
ridiculous amount of abuse I mean you
would be amazed what we put that truck
through and it never you know never
never flinched once the Ford Mustang
this is a car that was originally built
by pure vision you know that car was
probably somewhere between 700,000 and
the million dollar vehicle we had to
build several replicas but the hero car
that you see featured in all the
close-ups a hero car you see with the
hood off in the team's you know
headquarters was the true you know anvil
Mustang built by pure vision the car
community recognizes them they know the
car they know where it came from
they've seen it at the SEMA show they've
seen it in magazines so it's great that
there's cars like that out there from
you know other builders that we can
borrow to you know keep it exciting so
the the 2012 GTR at the very end of fast
sex this is that moment you know the end
of the movie there's not a lot of action
I want to go out and try to find the
best part car I possibly can and the
only problem arose when we got to set
and I said okay we want Brian to pull
into the driveway like ah God the drive
of Assistant gnarly approached angle and
we accomplished that but then of course
you know when I watched the movie that
part was cut out but we did make it
happen the 67 Camaro we did a lot of
modifications to make this car off-road
worthy you know coil over sway away how
scaring Iraq all the good stuff
[Music]
the the Subaru that we see Brian driving
in the plane sequence Rhys Millen did
the roll cage seats rally car suspension
we did have to give this car more boost
basically as we were shooting the
sequence up at Pikes Peak where we were
you know obviously starving for air we
up the boost as much as we could you
know it's still utilizing the stock
internals of the motor you know as
always the car was flawless never misses
a beat starts up every time compensated
for the altitude and got the job done I
think it would just disappoint every fan
the franchise if Brian wasn't in a GTR
at some point of the movie Brian's a
little mature now he's a little bit
older so we kind of eased up on the
modifications just did some very minimal
little carbon fiber treatment changed up
the seats change up the exhaust system
good friend of mine John comes in and
reprograms a system so it basically
divert snotty percent of the power to
the rear tires 10% of the front which is
just strictly done so we get those
massive you know overseer characteristic
rift scenes that we always have in the
franchise the 95 super is a car that was
a really meaningful moment for me
because this is after the passing of
Paul Walker the filming wasn't completed
and the scene was bit you know script
was basically rewritten where we had
this kind of parting of ways between DOM
and Brian so it was critical that I
found you know the best to possible cars
I could one of them being the Maximus
charger which I saw in its raw finish
widened body car had over 2,000
horsepower the only catch was it wasn't
completed yet the Supra was actually
Paul Walker's personal car and I think
it was you know the the right ending for
that film to have DOM and Brian in those
two vehicles the Challenger and seven
that Letty drives this is a car that you
know once again takes Letty back to her
her Mopar roots they were basically an
SRT 8 six-speed manual trans we added a
locking differential better clutch just
to handle the abuse of all the stunt
work some aggressive mufflers raised the
stance to handle the drop out of the
plane and the wing on the back was
basically an after thought it was a
story point I love the car Michelle
Rodriguez loved the car and it
definitely looked great on screen so the
lykan Hypersport this car was a real
tough one for me you know when I read
this graph I think my guy this is Dubai
these guys you know drive a Lamborghini
Aventador you know to Starbucks in the
morning what what am I going to feature
what can I put in this guy's you know
penthouse
somebody on the crew did hey check this
out oven oh my god I read about the car
I go it doesn't get any better than this
it's the first UAE produced supercar and
they're only going to build seven had
the hefty price tag of I think 3.7
million dollars but it was really
disappointed that there was only seven
produced and only seven guys we're going
to have it you know once I met the guys
at you know from like and we had a
meeting discussed the car discuss what
they could do for us we really had no
way to create these cars because we had
no moles we had no CAD data so they
actually built us the bodies gave us
some rollers on a you know based on a
Porsche Boxter chassis everything was
actual production quality just under the
skin it was you know it wasn't a 200
mile an hour car but luckily we were
only driving in the interior of the
building so I think 35 was as fast as we
ever had to go Fleetline Chevy is one of
my favorites I just really love the
fastback body style you know it just
kind of set it apart Dom's the underdog
he comes into this situation with you
know half the horsepower of his
competitor and all he has to rely on is
his his driving skill and his knowledge
of cars we have the nitrous gag we have
the valve we show how Dom hooks it all
up and it all makes sense
so the ice charger is another one of
these none of these vehicles that
basically gets partially designed by the
task at hand okay great we're on ice you
know what can we do what can what's the
right car with Dom you always kind of
gravitate towards the 68 and 70 Charger
is being kind of kind of like home base
form so what can I do to that car to
make it just plain mean and then the
other key factor is of course making it
all wheel drive you know you can stud
tires you can do every you can but a 200
drive car is it a huge disadvantage on
the ice the a arms are all custom
fabricated basically sitting the motor
back almost two feet to make room for a
front differential
we had to widen the track to make room
for the CV axles really the final
product did exactly what we wanted to do
is one of the few cars that we took out
to my first test session and out of all
the cars I built for the franchise is
probably my you know my new all-time
favorite so the ripsaw something that
I'd seen in the past I'd seen YouTube
videos of this vehicle in action when
you see the ripsaw it's really not that
massive I mean it's really probably
smaller than a Chevy Suburban you know
it's like yeah we've always got cool
cars and cool trucks but now we've
actually brought a tank into it so like
I said it was a fun one so
we haven't I hope you guys enjoyed going
through a little history of the cars at
the franchise make sure and check out
fate of the Furious you're going to love
it